en 1991 j'ai étudié en scénarisation
cinématographique dans ce film
autobiographique intitulé 1991
le réalisateur ricardo kôji revisitée de
ses 21 ans et cet été là il a fait son
tout premier voyage en europe pour
conquérir la femme de sa vie une
certaine barrière bernard un mélange de
cendrillon et d'animatrice de radio
comme il se plaît à le dire en italie ce
voyage en italie est pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
le jeune ricardo un étudiant de l'uqam
en cinéma et parfois tête en l'air il
fait de drôles de rencontres
il lui arrive toute source de mes
aventures en attendant de séduire celle
qui pourrait devenir la mère de ses
enfants
il ya un espagnol qui essayait de ma
volée s'est-elle ricardo trogi c'est
trop dit
cette histoire est la suite logique les
films 1981 et 1985
tubize un entre soi et comme dans ce
film on retrouve le même genre de
narration et les mêmes personnages est
toujours aussi coloré riccardo tozzi est
passé maître dans l'art de nous faire
voyager dans le temps que tu visant les
chansons les objets les grands sujets de
discussion de l'année 1991
forcément on se reconnaît on revit notre
premier voyage en europe en est la
première crise qu'on croyait
existentielle notre au procès la femme
de ma vie
le plus étonnant de 1991 c'est qu'il est
d'une sincérité désarmante très souvent
drôle parfois absurde
ce film est comme une carte postale de
notre passé que nous aurions retrouvé
par hasard
le mondial il est tellement vrai ce film
qu'on serait tenté de croire que ce
scénario a été écrit à partir de notre
propre histoire
j'ai donc aimé cette comédie grand
public saluons au passage la direction
photo de steve asselin qui nous montre l
italie dans toute sa splendeur
ici louis fait des queen radio canada
montréal